um
another question from the twitterverse
uh
who reads the books
i know you guys have answered this a lot
but i think it's um i think it's really
interesting to people just in terms of
of
knowing how the story is unfolding where
your character is headed um how many of
you guys actually read the books sophie
do you read the book um
i read the books season by season but my
chapters sorry guys
because well hey the books are really
complicated i can only just about manage
the tv series
they're amazing but complicated
[Applause]
so i just kind of know my storyline but
i don't want to
you know think my storyline is going off
in one direction
and then
because it's just an adaptation goes off
in a completely different one so um
season by season only my chapters so
it's like you know not too many pages
it's bad
um my
mom and step dad have both read the
books and they've told me roughly what
happens to arya
not every single
uh encounter along the way um
because i know that things changed like
i didn't meet tywin really in the books
and then that kind of came up in scripts
um
which is great and then things like
weasel soup didn't happen
um
but yeah i guess i know roughly what
happens to her so then you just
wait till the scripts come and then see
what you're actually uh going to be
doing and then when all this finishes i
do really want to read them but i'm kind
of confused
a bit at the moment so
yeah uh yeah but i do really want to
read them so
i've read them
this is awkward because i'm sitting next
to george
um i haven't read them
i speak to a lot of people about them
because
seemingly a lot of people have
and uh
it's interesting to get
different takes
on characters and then of course
we have
the words from david and dan so
i just i let it unfold i kind of like to
be
surprised
but i'm scared i'm now gonna die
yeah
well time to kill another lannister
um yeah i i um
with all apologies to george and
just in such
i'm so in awe of this man um but uh
i i don't want to know what happens to
me
down the road i'm terrified and i don't
want to play any sort of ending uh
when i'm doing this show and i just live
and breathe this show
and
i
i uh
i'm so embarrassed when i have to run
you
yeah
do you know how often we get asked this
question and i go hold on what then i
just say welcome um
i'm also going to ask who you're dating
at some point yeah
um i also
i can't
subtract the show from the book so
i you know i'm that guy who has a really
hard time reading the book after he sees
the movie because i'll just
i'll just picture steven dorf you know
um
okay uh
sorry
if you could let me know what movie
stephen dorf did that was based on a
book
[Laughter]
i'm just interested in why you thought
of stephen door
it's just the first actor that came to
my head
and he's he comes to my head all the
time
now we're getting somewhere yeah
oh now we're going somewhere i just
would picture my friends on the show and
uh i i will i'm going to read them when
we're after my character now gets killed
yes i've i've read the first four not
the latest one
all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
um i couldn't help myself when i got the
part i and
you know it's based on books i
went i read them
very quickly actually because i i just
wanted to know what happened to my
character and i
then got way too ahead of myself and had
to you know reel it back in and yeah so
i have written yeah
yeah i read per season
yeah
and i must admit i did take a leaf out
of sophie's book as well
like
look for the title of your character
and then of course
fill in the dots in between
well like with maisie my mum read the
book
[Laughter]
and she did a really good summary
[Applause]
uh dan and david can you talk a little
bit about um
which characters that you found the most
general die
we suddenly um
uh which characters did you find the
most challenging to cast
and why um arya yeah arya i would say we
probably saw more
more people for for arya and daenerys
than than any other characters i mean we
must have seen how many muslim 300
arias
and this one was she was one of the very
very we we were kind of there just
nobody was right nobody there were a
couple of a couple of kids who who
felt very actory who who felt like they
just you know they they've kind of gone
through that child actor processing
machine that turns out
some talented people but you know
they're good for kind of what child
actors are usually cast as which is
roles you know they're that are not as
adult as this and just nobody had that
that
realness we were looking for and and one
of the very last faces we saw was was
maisie's face on the cast it is the name
of the program that you cast with the
window you know it's a little window
this big we just saw that face this big
we were like please be good
we were on a location to go to morocco
and we're at the hotel and have very
very dodgy internet connection and we're
so you can click on the
link for maisie's audition you're
waiting you're watching like the little
line
oh and we're just seeing this tiny
little thumbnail picture of a face that
looked so perfect and waiting and
waiting and waiting and then it was
probably literally 30 to 10 seconds into
the audition we were like yep she's the
one and then we had a chemistry read
actually with um with those two maizie
and sophie got together and
um and it was love at first sight
is that where you guys met because um i
read a lot about you guys being really
great friends you met at the audition
yeah um
i did
my first audition that i guess you
watched and then um i did another
audition meeting other girls who were
playing
sansa
um and i got on really really well with
sophie and just remember her being like
super tall and
and like after everything we do she's
like oh you're really cute
and then i was a bit like yeah i'm only
one year younger than you
but um yeah we got on really really well
and um i came out of the audition and
said to my mom i was like even if i
don't get the part i really want that
girl too because she's really cool so
yeah
oh you're really cute
phil only one year younger
anybody else have an interesting casting
story
well jason
momoa came in and of his own free will
after doing his audition he did
the it's what's it the haka maori the
maori war dance which was not written
into the scene
it actually didn't have anything to do
with the scene but it i would say it
impressed us he did
he did the hell out of it he really did
so that was yeah that was another really
hard hard roll
to to cast back in the day was was uh
was called drogo and surprisingly and
you had peter in mind
yeah peter actually before i think even
the deal was done with hbo i sent you an
email i'd met peter before
at a dinner or something or other and
he ignored me
talked to my wife the whole night but
i remember thinking he's really smart
he's very funny as you've seen tonight
and and uh you know
when we when we thought we might have a
shot to do this but before we actually
had the deal because the deal took a
long time to make um send them a note
and that you'd already heard about the
books and the character i think
and then we met and do you remember what
you said you had it in one demand it won
the man
said no no beer beards no long beard
it's done with the long beards
i just never understood why in fantasy
dwarves always
[Laughter]
no offense to mr tolkien
but uh and you know i think i had just
done the narnia movie a couple years
before we met and
so we had to rewrite the whole script
and yet you wear a beard tonight
it's not down to my knees
[Laughter]
some of these the hollywood beard
the fact that the books existed before
we began to cast a show
and it had so many fans led to a
phenomenon that a a show that was not
based on books would not have that is
the minute the show was announced
i began to get
tapes
pictures links to youtube performances
of the major characters by would-be
actors from
literally all over the world and of
course i'm in santa fe new mexico i was
weighing in on some of the casted
auditions but i wasn't in the casting
session i just sent all this stuff on to
on to uh dan and david uh here's another
one that
showed up on youtube some of them
weren't half bad but some of them
were frighteningly bad
and frighteningly inappropriate
according to the
the characters as described in the books
but uh you know but
i mean it's it's sincere i don't want to
you know
ridiculous too much i know there are
people out there with dreams and all
that uh but uh
it's really not the way you you can't
get cast in a major television
show by
putting it up on youtube and asking the
fans to campaign for you or or by
sending off the fact that you were in a
school play and here's a here's a
picture of
your performance as othello or something
like that
uh well we're running low on time but i
wanted to ask something that i'm sure
everybody here really is uh wondering
where um where are you in the series how
how close are you
well i'm writing book six
uh the winds of winter
um and of course i'm uh
starting to worry because everybody's
asking me what are you going to do if
david and dan and the show catches up to
you
uh
which is beginning to scare me i didn't
think it was a problem before but uh
they're moving faster than i am i have a
i have not uh failed to notice this i i
feel sometimes as if i'm uh i'm laying
track for a railroad and i can hear the
locomotive coming up here
and it's building speed and i see the
smoke and i hear the whistle coming and
i better keep laying that track pretty
pretty fast here because uh i'll get
squashed if the locomotive comes but i
still have a considerable lead at least
that's what i'm telling myself
season three is uh the first only the
first half of book three so season four
will be the second half of book three
and then i have i have book four and
book five uh those are gigantic books
which have to be recombined because
they're actually parallel
but i'm hoping those will be at least
two seasons maybe three
that will get me some time to finish
book six and by that then by the time
they're up
they'll be doing that season and i'll be
writing book seven
that's my story and i'm sticking to it
well on that note
that's going to conclude our evening so
let's give it up one more time to all
the time